now one thing I found fascinating about
your new book is the fact that it shows
us the world beyond we're seeing and
shows us countries and places that are
influenced maybe by Asia or North Africa
or the Middle East but for the most part
fantasy is very monocultural you know I
you watch the film with the habitants
there no black hobbits walking up and
down and and or even a game of Thrones a
lot of the main not many of the main
characters are people of color and I'm
wondering what what why in your opinion
is fantasy so monocultural and what
could be done to change that well I
think this is a relatively simple answer
it's it's it's so monocultural cuz it's
mostly been written by white men and you
know I'm a 66 year old white man Tolkien
was a I don't know what age he was but
you know he was born in the 19th century
in England and he was an Oxford Don they
lived in small English towns his entire
life and we look back on our own history
and the cultures and things we were
taught raised up on the legends of Robin
Hood and and King Arthur and you know
Tolkien was a expert on Beowulf and all
that and that's true of many of the
Tolkien imitators even even the people
writing it today are all drawn from the
same cultural pool so that's largely why
it is what has been up to the present
however I do see evidence that that's
changing if you if you look at the the
world science fiction award do you go
which is given every year and the john w
campbell award which has award for the
best new writer that's given every year
at the world SF convention more and more
of them have been writers a very
different ethnic backgrounds more and
more women
women of color when women from other
countries of Indian descent of you know
black writers like NK jemisin and Nandi
oaken for Asian writers like Ken Liu
these guys have won that Campbell Award
and they're coming out with books of
their own and they're drawing from
different cultural traditions from from
their own traditions be they you know
Japanese or African or Chinese whatever
at not historical novels mind you but
fantasy novels but but drawn from that
tradition and some of them are doing
very fine work now the question the
impact that they have on the field is
largely gonna be determined by you guys
I mean if these books sell publishers
will publish more of them they'll be
made into movies they'll be made into
television shows and if those are
successful there will be more movies and
more television shows Hollywood in
particular is very imitative if they
don't succeed though and the books by
you know the old white guys continue to
succeed then you'll get more books by
old white guys so I actually like to
think of myself as an old white guy
who's really 16 inside but you know this
there's that